direction l'italie rome fou le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères s'est
entretenu avec le premier ministre mario
draghi est le chef de la diplomatie
italienne parmi les sujets abordés
l'afghanistan visite suivie par notre
envoyé spécial mon âme ou dès lors
les échanges entre sergueï lavrov et
luigi di maio on était je cite très
productif selon le chef de la diplomatie
italienne
beaucoup de sujets sur l'actualité
internationale ont été abordés bien
évidemment la situation en afghanistan
était au coeur des discussions
luigi di maio indiqué que l'italie
serait très regardantes sur l'évolution
de la situation à kaboul notamment pour
les droits de l'homme les droits des
femmes mais également concernant à
l'acheminement de l'aide écoutez le
et la priorité pour nous l'état laisse
et de garantir les droits de l'homme les
droits des femmes les droits des enfants
et les organisations internationales
doivent pouvoir avoir un accès sur le
terrain pauvre pouvoir acheminer une
aide
à ceux qui en ont besoin
et notre communauté internationale doit
préparer cette aide de son côté ça gagne
lavrov a fermement condamné la dernière
attaque à kaboul et insisté sur les
leçons à tirer de l'occupation
américaine écoutez il ya quand même des
[Musique]
leçons à tirer après la libye après
l'irak après l'afghanistan encore une
fois on voit qu'il ne faut pas chercher
à importer imposer des systèmes de
valeurs à d'autres pays cela crée des
situations explosives
et donc je pense que quand on crée une
politique
à long terme il faut sur les autres pays
il faut quand même prendre en compte les
réalités locales les deux homologues ont
également abordé le cas de la libye et
ont confirmé le retrait de leurs troupes
pays où la situation est au bord de
l'implosion est les questions
européennes ont également été abordés
sergueï lavrov le chef de la diplomatie
russe en a profité pour tacler les pays
européens qui font la promotion
d'un sentiment antirusse écoutez nous
avons fait part de nos appréciations
de des dirigeants
de l'union européenne
qui maintiennent leurs humeurs anti
russe anti russie et il ya un certain
nombre de pays osso fob qui continue à
être actif nous avons parlé de la
situation en ukraine
nous avons une position similaire
sur la nécessité de s'en tenir aux
accords de minsk mais nous avons donné
des exemples concrets
de la des amendements la constitution la
législation ukrainienne qui sont
proposés qui vise à ne pas respecter les
accords de et donc la situation
particulièrement complexe et des
échanges qui seront prolongées lors du
g20 sommet capital selon à luigi di maio
le chef de la diplomatie italienne un
sommet qui permettra notamment de
renforcer et d'approfondir la
coopération et des pays face aux
conflits internationaux